happy monday oh it's a glorious monday
what a joy
if you haven't been murdered yet by a
nut bag it's true we have an epidemic of
crazy people what we used to call the
criminally deranged or the views
audience but they're everywhere on the
streets on the subway one is sitting to
my right
but they're also in our city halls our
governments in our district attorney's
offices from new york to chicago to la
to baltimore and they're spreading
faster than omicron
it's not funny anymore on saturday
morning a maniac waited as a train
entered the times square subway station
before he happily pushed an asian woman
to her death
michelle elisa go aged 40 was murdered
that morning the killer stuck his tongue
out at the police like a third grader
out the window of a school bus the
perfect metaphor for bail reform or any
other garbage that passes a social
justice reform but if you dare ask why
was he out on the street well you're
probably racist
or worse a republican
meanwhile this punk just murdered a
teenager allegedly in a bronx burger
king
it's his idea of having it his way under
the new attorney general here he is
shouting about reparations and slavery
[Music]
hell he sounds like every democrat
member of congress when they're on
twitter
and if you disagree with him well you're
probably racist too meanwhile on the
opposite coast the ucla grad student was
fatally stabbed by you guessed it a
deranged creep brianna kupfer aged 24
was alone working when a man believed to
be homeless knifed her to death
why was he out on the streets with a
knife
that's probably your fault because you
just don't care enough there's also
sandra shells a hard-working nurse who
died after being attacked by a homeless
man near the la union station he's
probably just down on his luck
then there's george gascon the city's
woke d.a who says he doesn't want to
send another deranged maniac a 26 year
old transgender woman to jail for
sexually assaulting a ten-year-old girl
over fears that the deviant will be
attacked
oh yeah god forbid a guard uses the
wrong pronoun gascon recommends home
confinement for the perv because these
trans
cool george how does the guest bedroom
in your house sound you
clown but if you agree with me i bet
that makes you transphobic
i gotta hand it to the deviant they're
grifting the grift meaning they see how
to exploit the woken sanity with the
help of progressive lawyers they are
awoke to the woke if you will
by the way can we stop calling these
people woke
they're as woke as the statues they love
to tear down
meanwhile those woke prosecutors may not
be criminally deranged but they're
racking up impressive numbers that would
make any batman villain envious the only
thing that separates them from the
psychos they're setting free is a trip
to the men's warehouse and a thesaurus
the joker has nothing on larry krasner
under that fool philly has gone from a
low of 248 murders in 2014 to 562
killings in 2020 a new all-time record
if only the eagles offense could put up
those kind of numbers yesterday
like i have watched the game the victims
of this violence are almost entirely
non-whites living in the poorest parts
of the city but if you plead for
solutions you'd probably be called a
racist
because lots of those killers are also
black
how the kkk couldn't ask for a better
solution do nothing
meanwhile chicago under kim fox has seen
more than 800 homicides in 2021 levels
not seen since the 80s crack at 90s
crack epidemic the good news fox has
saved the city a few billion dollars by
not prosecuting homicides so you go girl
and if you don't like what she's doing
well then you're probably racist and
misogynist
of course there's the hostage crisis at
the synagogue in texas where an
anti-semitic fiend took a rabbi among
others hostage in order to free a
terrorist initially the fbi said this
attack wasn't related to the jewish
community
probably they were waiting to pin it on
a white supremacist we have seen an
incredible rise
uh in rhetoric that is anti-semitic
being trafficked all around the country
because we were seeing an exponential
rise in hate crimes and an exponential
rise in the formation and the membership
of these extremist organizations many of
which are white supremacy organizations
way to jump the gun you jackass of
course even mentioning the maniacs
religion makes you islamophobic and we
don't want to make the squad cry again
i just hope the hostage situation won't
keep the bite administration from going
after those domestic terrorists
attending school board meetings or
voting rights acts
i'll defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies
and yes domestic
yes domestic
what a great time to be alive if you're
criminally deranged because you got us
you paralyzed our weak leaders with the
fear of being smeared as racist or worse
a republican if they try to fix anything
so they now accept the idea that random
crazies can murder innocent people
especially on the streets where
homelessness is the go-to choice by
unhinged people and an unhinged person
will likely commit unhinged activity no
one in power makes this connection the
person who chooses to live crazily
is more likely to do crazy things fish
swim in water bears roam the woods and
the criminally deranged wander the
streets punching asian women and thanks
to progressive das it'll happen again
another student murdered another asian
woman killed and why is it always asians
i'm thinking these street thugs aren't
doing it in retaliation for the wuhan
lab leak
now when i was a kid i saw movies like
the warriors death wish sudden impact
gangs roamed and committed inexplicable
violence
how quaint does that seem now because
even in those movies we at least
admitted criminal behavior was evil
and it was the good cop against the evil
criminals the lines were clearly drawn
but in our world today it's good cop
versus criminals and also versus the
corrupt justice system which is scarier
than all the halloween movies combined
[Applause]
tonight's guests
he's a monocle away from being the
actual monopoly guy host of kudlow on
fox business and former director of the
national economic council the great
larry kudlow
she's never let a defendant take the
fifth of her vodka
outnumbered coho's emily cumpagno
and his beard has antibodies against
just for men
writer and comedian joe devito
and janice steen mistakes her for a
wintry mix because she's a white mess on
the ground fox news contributor cat tim
[Applause]
all right emily welcome to the show
thank you maybe on soul train later
oh
i like my outfit i do like it too i do
like it too but it's you know it's a
retro jumpsuit kind of thing i was
complimenting you don't get me in
trouble with hr emily all right here's
the thing that i've noticed that there
are no more sane criminals like any time
something happens where somebody is
murdered they will okay even including
the the um the transgendered the male to
female trans they're saying he's
developmentally disabled it's almost
like these progressive da's are building
a force field around people that are
arrested oh they're insane they're
mentally ill clearly some of them are
but every one of them they are creating
the most vulnerable victims to be the
ones that are the defendants they are
creating they're putting them into such
a tiny box that then we have to protect
to them let's talk about this crime
explosion for a second so law
enforcement last year solved more
homicides than they had in five years
but because the homicide rate had
skyrocketed the clearance rate actually
declined and the issue people aren't
dabbling in shoving people off the
subway platform into the tracks it is
the same people that are committing the
same crimes over and over and over again
it is a recidivist rate so even before
kovid two-thirds of every violent
offender that had served time were
rearrested for another violent felony
within five years now there is no
deterrent consequences whatsoever that
pool has brought in so much let's take
your girl hannah you know what she did
it says assault in a bathroom she took
the ten-year-old by the throat she
shoved her into the stall locked her in
and then shoved her hand down her pants
and groped her she was also arrested for
in other states battery drug abuses
other offenses violating parole and the
like throughout the country and this is
the kind of person that gascon wants to
protect you want to protect someone in
prison you put them in the shoe the
specialty housing unit the solitary
housing unit there are ways in prison
via the department of corrections to
keep someone safe right unless you're a
whitey bulger but otherwise guess what i
don't give
she's trans she has to stay home because
she's trans and i wonder
god what a great
scam by the way to your point about the
uh about the rediscipism or recidivism
you know i don't like saying that word
recidivism because it's hard
but
do you know one of us one of our
staffers actually recognized the subway
pusher because he'd been pleasuring
himself often on the street and this is
something that is regular if somebody is
masturbating publicly on the street
chances are he's mentally ill and should
probably be behind bars for other things
but i you know that was just an
interesting fact that now i can't get
out of my head
larry
how are you
you weren't referring to the cnn legal
analyst
nicely done chicken
chicken yes very
very good what do we do oh by the way
isn't it weird how we can't deduce that
somebody who lives on the street might
be inclined to violence like we can't
even say like if there if there is a
large group of people on the street
chances are they're willing to take
other risks
right yes
they're probably more rational than
anyone wants to believe i'm not an
expert yeah here's what i know no bail
no jail this is what you get okay people
who have male problems fine deal with
them but they should be done so while
they're under incarceration yes i'm
sorry you don't let them out on the
street you've had this wave of
lawlessness
it started i don't know a couple years
ago joe biden's america seems to be
characterized by it nobody wants to put
anybody in jail everybody's got a reason
a liberal left-wing reason i'm sorry
folks want to be safe okay even legal
analysts at the other network yeah if
he's safe and the fact remains put them
in jail look what's going on here in new
york city with this guy
half of his staff just walked out right
okay they just left because they're
prosecutors they could be democrats they
could be republican they could be
progressives i don't know who they are
they are beliefs they believe in law
enforcement so they hear hishtik and
they just up and leave the guy in los
angeles is a joke people in chicago what
is it 15 major cities across the country
with record homicide rates now are they
crazy they may be crazy but they should
be crazy in jail i'm sorry that's where
they belong exactly you know joe i the
one thing that's that's harming this is
the idea of context when you hear about
a crime oh you're missing the context
this person has been in and out of
institutions this person had a rough
life no no no
just need a variable victim
perp sure yeah well you know people seem
to be forgetting you could be mentally
ill and right they're not mutually
exclusive
and
one of the things i think that we're not
hearing about enough is that these
violent people on the street most of
their victims are other street people
who are very vulnerable because of their
addictions in mental illness and all
that good point but we're in this weird
situation where we have society split
into another
two groups well three groups actually
you have people at the top who make laws
but don't obey them you have the elites
at the very bottom you have a lawless
class that's causing all this trouble
they're chaotic they're dysfunctional
but no one arrests them no one keeps
them in jail there's no incentive to not
commit a crime and in between you have
everyone else like us who's getting
squeezed yeah because you call the cops
you might get arrested right it's very
easy to come up to that family that
their kid's mask has slid down in a
restaurant and stick the cops on them
that's an easy case that appeals to the
people on top but to go and say where's
the guy who's going around harassing
people on the subway they don't want to
do that the same day the same day that
the subway push happened i guess
was an arrested applebee's for a protest
an anti-vaxx protest or something like
that that's what we're doing kat this
weekend you spent quite a long time with
the mayor
um
i
i talked to the mayor for like a minute
at a comedy show yes but he came over he
recognized you which means he watches
this show which means he could be
watching right now and we asked him to
be on his on this show cat and his staff
said he was too busy but not busy enough
to go to a car
hey mayor well you know what this isn't
funny anymore
why am i yelling you could just turn me
down or turn me up cat what say you how
is your relationship with the mayor
going to help this
well given my very very close
relationship that i now have with the
mayor i'd say not quite best friends but
almost there yes um very impactful man i
i'm going to have a huge influence here
you should be his miranda
oh geez um
look i just don't see why this is
controversial i think this would be if i
were mayor which i'm sure i will be
someday yes um especially now that i
have my mentor eric adams who i spent so
much time with and talked to you for so
long yes uh this shouldn't be
controversial of all the things that you
can you know stand on the side of i feel
like violent criminals is an easy one to
be like no let's pick something else i i
want to do away with almost every law
but i do draw the line at like rape
murder those sorts of things those
should be illegal i don't get i feel
like no matter what you believe in
all of us i feel like it's pretty
important to us to get you know not get
murdered yes how does cam feel about
your relationship with the mayor
he was getting a look look i mean he was
getting a little nervous just because we
were connecting on such a deep level
it was weird
it was at a comedy club it's super loud
and it's packed but there was you two
just like eyes and tent just a lot can
happen in one minute yeah it was it was
the eye lock the eye lock itself it was
just insane and i thought maybe you and
him together could solve this problem oh
one minute is this the first at the
beginning of very many to come there you
go hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else